Yes
[Music]
Every time I see stones passing by, I
think of the center and see if
this will happen Theory People
keep looking for the unimaginable center,
so I think it’s my ability.
My name is Rocky Byun.
I am a
balancing artist
[Music]
Uhh
]
[Music]
I started from that time in 2005. At
first, I mainly listened to stones.
As an evil, I made a combination in
.
Now, this has become a profession.
No matter how difficult it is for me to look at such a complex centering term, I
do not have gravity as a thing. I
use it to focus
Mobile phone file
The military has to build a motorcycle that is out of frame
If you look at
it, you can see that we are living in a hurry. Then, let's live again and
live a little slower. Talk about it a
lot. I think it happened because I am positive and confident
that I am a person who can produce results for everything after I resigned from the resident
[Music]